[Music]
normally new releases
picks the five hottest upcoming games to
talk about but this episode is a major
exception
with the next gen consoles launching
this month it would be a real disservice
to limit ourselves to just 5 games
so strap in for a jumbo length episode
that takes an overall look at november
including next gen launches and more
let's kick things off with the xbox
series xns launch
one of their biggest day one games is
assassin's creed valhalla
the latest in the series takes the
assassin action to the viking era
where you'll lead your tribe as the
mighty avor you'll lead your people in
an invasion of great britain
raiding villages and building up your
own encampments
valhalla comes to ps4 xbox one series
xns
pc and stadia on tuesday november 10th
it comes to ps5 a few days later
on the 12th dirt 5 will already be out
on current jan and pc by the time the
new xboxes are here
but the rally racing game is also a
next-gen launch title
the latest in the series offers tracks
all around the world
dynamic weather and seasons and even
local split-screen multiplayer races
you can also take on a rival driver in
career mode
dirt 5 comes to series x and s on the
10th and to ps5
on the 12th speaking of going around the
world
let's make a stop at the mysterious
island home of the bug snacks
this cutesy looking game is from the
minds behind octodad
and it tasks you with catching the
titular bug snacks as you explore a
mysterious island
it is a ps5 launch game but you can also
catch your snacks on ps4 and pc
starting thursday the 12th and now the
theme song is stuck in your head
[Music]
and now for a completely different tone
with the demon souls remake
the same team that brought shadow of the
colossus to ps4 is added again
with a ps5 remake of the game that
started this whole soulsborne trend
some of the older mechanics are a bit
different from what strict dark souls
fans are used to
but you'll still be face to face with
some massive and macabre bosses
demon souls launches exclusively
alongside the ps5 on the 12th
ps5's other major launch day exclusive
is spider-man miles morales
like the name says you're playing as a
different spidey in this stand-alone
adventure
and miles has his own set of suits and
special powers to show off
including invisibility and bursts of
electricity don't worry if you're not
planning on picking up the ps5 at launch
though
this game is also coming to ps4 you can
take a swing at it on the 12.
let's talk about one more ps5 console
exclusive
godfall this looter slasher from gearbox
is set in a world divided by the
elements of fire
water earth air and spirit you can
choose from five different night classes
as you fight foes and unlock
all kinds of loot as you'd expect from a
game like this
you can drop in and out of co-op with
your friends while playing
as far as consoles you'll only be able
to play godfall on ps5
but it's also coming to pc on the 12th
let's move out of launch day now with
another much anticipated november game
call of duty black ops cold war it's a
retelling of the events that followed
the first black ops game
set during the reagan era expect a
campaign full of twists and turns
as well as all the usual multiplayer
modes plus some new ones thanks to fire
team
and yes zombies are back too you can
experience all that on ps4
ps5 xbox one series xns
and pc on friday the 13th
we can't end this episode without giving
nintendo some love
and luckily there's a switch exclusive
on the way too hyrule warriors age of
calamity brings the musso action back to
hyrule
but this time you'll be playing a
hundred years before the events of
breath of the wild
link zelda impa and the four champions
are all playable as you fight the forces
of calamity ganon and solve puzzles in
the style of classic zelda games
the age of calamity begins on friday the
20th
and those are just some of the hottest
games launching this month
there are more than we can fit into this
video of course so be sure to head to
gamespot for the complete list
as always remember that release dates
are based on retailer listings and are
subject to change
thanks for watching everyone and i'll be
back with a closer look at more november
games next sunday
you